[Musique]
pas une fois je me le suis même tordu la
cheville a pas le choix
à partir de maintenant je ne doit plus
être le seul à connaître la formule de
la potion magique ou 1
je mets donc partir à la recherche d'un
jeune successeur à qui il a confié coin
tu sais ce qui se passerait si la
puissance de la potion magique tomber
dans n'importe quelles mains d'hommes
avez-vous en tête la liste des jeunes
truites gaulois bien côté je crois qu'on
doit décrire des fétiches la petite
fille cette maison impeccable doute
incurable
c'est super dur cela ils sont pas fichus
de faire une soupe à l'oignon ici est
mauvais mais qui arrive quand même à
bricoler deux trois trucs on me surnomme
magnétique
et là les très bons
tu vas y mollo sur la frime quand même
avec césar de cette caution je te le
donnerai la potion des dingos kiri cette
manigance ce furent x ce soir c'est la
fin du village de crétins moustachu la
fin d' astérix
je verse salade du tambora druide
pourquoi ce serait plus dur que de beaux
souvenirs
détroit
c'est qu'elle parte il faut taper
pourquoi ton mais ça tu sais bien ce que
ça fait chaque fois j'ai modifié à dix
ça peut exploser
c'est que c'est bon ça explosera plus
si tu es aussi bon droit que poissonnier
va y avoir de la performance alors
qu'est ce qu'il raconte degrolard 10h25
à quel âge tu veux faire le show du coup
bah oui c'est fini non moi je pense que
je devais être sur la fin fin
[Musique]
hossegor laissez le tranquille
c'est un monde très dur et il le devient
sans cesse un peu plus le monde ne
changera pas y'a quelqu'un c'est toi qui
doit changer
il s'est passé un truc incroyable
on va voir ce que j'ai trouvé quelque
chose est écrit sur la garde regarde
dans google traduction
ça veut dire et paix d'arthur excalibur
l'épée dans la pierre alexander et bien
c'est toi pierre sortir et paix le
croyons couvre un danger mortel
il reste quatre jours jusqu'à l'équipe
solaire alors morgan entrera dans le
monde des vivants
je suis censé la stopper c'est n'importe
quoi
j'ai douze heures
je croyais de merlin est un vieil homme
tu as l'air de voir saison une
couverture ingénieuse pour te surveiller
incognito
tu devras rassembler une équipe de
chevalier ce d'arthur se réunissaient
autour d'une table ronde pour qu'ils
soient tous égaux et regardez vite
bidders les rabats de la table vous
voyez alors toi t'es trop geek c'est le
destin
à nous cinq on n'aura pas la moindre
chance il faut lever une armée qui veut
se joindre à nous quelle humiliation
ceux ci remplacera les cours aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
tu vomis calais
la pire chose est la meilleure
c'est terrible et la plus géniale qui me
soit jamais arrivée
ou est ce que tu as appris à conduire
mario kart
maman ne fuit pas d'accord dame du lac
veuillez rendre xcalibur
ceci est l'histoire d'un voleur tu
voulais voler à toi de jouer
il volait aux riches pour donner aux
pauvres
c'est tout ce que tu as je l'appelle
robin des bois
vous croyez qu'il est au courant
le chief il y a qu une chose qu ils
maintiennent au pouvoir l'argent je veux
voler le trésor du royaume
comment tu veux faire organiser une
réunion avec tous ceux qui sont avec
nous
rob a comment to flex mot la belle santé
du sport sera fermée tous les autres
c'est du jeu celui-ci bienvenue à la
cour des grands
n'auriez vous pas ce que vous faites
vous êtes un modèle pour le peuple c'est
notre croisade
ils sont trop nombreux quoi pour toi et
moi ils sont pas assez
miliband à lui qui me lie barrage de
polar ça va pas bien se terminer
tous en rythme allait avec moi ok sur le
troisième on tape des mains
il se passe quoi ici tu me serais le
site était ponctuelle je veux donner au
public une chanson à interpréter
et qu'est ce qu'il peut faire yves agid
entendre des billets de jean thiffault
sensible et les paroles dans tout ça
[Applaudissements]
oui
vous connaissez miami vous allez adorer
costume avec les baskets et réfute tu te
fous de moi non mais regardez qui voit
la walck lob de julio iglesias
and we
où vas tu chéris papa est mort ce matin
j'ai besoin d'être seul
tu n'auras markram impact suis parti
tout va bien on joue à cache cache
voir
[Musique]
bienvenue à tous nous commencerons avec
un exercice si jamais j'étais premier
ministre
milliards tu commences la douche bien
tout le monde est le bienvenu
quelles que soient ses origines ou sa
nationalité et si j'étais élu premier
ministre c'est la première chose que je
défendrai nouvelle dernière minute
une énorme explosion vient de retentir
en plein centre ville
en attendant qu'on en sache un peu plus
toutes nos activités sont suspendues
d'accord bonjour police d'oslo vous êtes
au courant pour l'explosion oui on m'a
envoyé pour sécuriser lille
excusez moi je pourrais voir votre carte
oui bien sûr
c'était quoi sa fausseté règle il
s'agirait tout attaques coordonnées la
menace d'attentats et à son livre le
plus haut
ou nvidia il ya eu de graves manquements
dans le système et nous devons savoir
les qualifs c'est le seul moyen de
surmonter cette épreuve
je veux lui faire comprendre ce qu'il y
avait je vais être plus fort que lui
c'est peut-être l'occasion l'homme
qu'ils ont arrêtés il veut que je le
représente
pourquoi toi je dois poser des questions
à certains témoins ce n'est pas le
procès de la norvège
c'est le vôtre vous en êtes bien sûr
je veux pas avoir l'air faible pas
devant lui
tu peux être faible et fort à la fois tu
le sais ça
j'ai encore la chance d'avoir de
l'espoir
les rêves
une famille
des amis
j'ai choisi de vivre
regarde-moi on va s'en sortir témoin
confiance
[Musique]
[ __ ]
johnson
[Applaudissements]
you came
[Musique]
m
k
c'est un peu court
[Musique]
y a
les miroirs
quand
[Musique]
antoine gatier
on s'ennuie tellement fermé ici dehors
c'est le cas il fait très froid et ça
fourmille de brigands j'ai envie de
sortir je veux aller à casteau kg à
tokyo
c'est beaucoup trop loin
oscar les chats ne sont pas des oiseaux
ils ne peuvent pas voler vos les regarde
j'ai fabriqué une fusée partait dans une
incroyable aventure avec vos stars
découvrir le monde des chats
[Musique]
devant le sauver
je ne le vois plus
comment chatons l'intérieur atterrissent
pourquoi tu cherches 4 stopyra je n'ai
pas envie de devenir aussi paresseux
pour faire annuler
cet endroit 4 stockage est ce mal existe
c'est un monde légendaire qui n'existe
que dans les coeurs mais c'est dangereux
ça bruisse bessora toulabor kevin love
les autres animaux je n'ai pas peur ça
reste quand même très dangereux
ce qui n'est pas
ban
winfrey
ce vaste monde est à toi les couvre le
soin audacieux oscars et
le 12 décembre au cinéma
[Musique]